now on monday the eyes of the world will
return to minneapolis
the scene of george floyd's killing the
city is braced for the trial of derek
chauvin a former police officer accused
of murdering mr floyd
the trial's being hailed as one of the
most important in u.s history and a
defining moment
for the nation and the civil rights
movement and joining me now to discuss
this is martin luther king
the third civil rights activist and the
son of martin luther king jr thank you
so much for joining us
um we'll get to george floyd and the
court case in a moment but i just wanted
to talk to you about um
a new voting law in georgia among other
things that imposes new id
requirements for mail-in voting limits
the availability of ballot drop boxes
a host of other things a 98-page measure
um it's been likened to the racist
policies of
the of um the deep south
um said that it's this the president
excuse me says it disproportionately
targets black americans
what do you make of this new law well
there's no question about that
the law was signed by the governor i
believe on thursday
and immediately a number of
community organizations came together to
file a lawsuit
there's even a small provision or a
provision in this law that says
if you bring water to someone who is
standing in line who may have been
standing in line for four or five hours
it is a crime it is the most inhumane
kind of thing that i've ever seen and
the only reason that it exists
is because um you know
on january 5th the state of georgia
elected its first black senator and its
first
jewish senator john ossoff reverend
murphy on walnut
uh who's the pastor of ebenezer church
where my father was co-pastor
um and and the the second issue of
course in november of last year
we had an election and for the first
time the state of georgia elected
uh the voted for the democratic ticket
uh president biden and vice president
harris
so clearly this provision is only
to stifle and slow down black
people students browns people
and others from voting it really makes
no sense in fact the governor
and the secretary of state said we had
no issues with the election in november
nor the election on january 5th so why
they would come and create these
draconian law
laws is very suspect and the fact
that they do hearken back to jim crow
the jim crow era
where blacks were not allowed to
register because they'd ask questions
like
well how high is up or how many bottle
bubbles are in a bottle
of soap who knows those answers um so
jim crow just to give
some sort of context there were laws
that enforced racial segregation and
they were actually enforced until the
mid
60s um donald trump
he lost georgia by about 12 000 votes
last year he has celebrated these
changes you mentioned the governor brian
kemp he said
there's nothing jim crow about requiring
a photo or state issued id to vote by
absentee ballot
every georgia voter must already do so
when voting in person
president biden the left and the
national media are determined to destroy
the sanctity and security of the ballot
box what do you say to that
well first of all when you talk about
reducing
polling hours and play places for
example we used to have maybe a month
and a half
to vote early they cut that back
maybe to less than 30 days there are
were certain boxes
where you could go and drop off your
ballots
now you have to have some kind of
notification or notarized uh
scenario uh to make sure your ballot is
legal it's all it
and again some of these things maybe if
there was any proof of fraud of some
kind
in fact there was no fraud at all the
only thing that happened
is more people voted than ever before
and they want to restrict people
it's interesting that we call ourselves
a democracy
and we operate around the world talking
about
uh imposing or encouraging other
countries to engage in democracy
but yet right at home we are suppressing
democracy
it's not about an id that's not the
issue
the fact of the matter is in black
communities in brown communities
there are lines sometimes that take
hours to vote
and because of that you should open up
more lines or add more days for voting
there are provisions that you do to
expand the right to vote
not to subtract and reduce and what
these people have done
is they have created a scenario to
subtract
by the way just as they signed the law
in the governor's office and one of the
state representatives
was arrested for knocking on the door
when public business was being done
and other legislators were in there but
they did not want her in there
and so they arrested a sitting state
representative
who was trying to be a part of the
process because she represents georgians
also
that's just unconscionable what this
state has done it's a sad
sad time for the state of georgia and
i think for the united states because
there are 40 more states
that are also looking at legislation
in my reading about this i came across
um deborah scott the executive director
of georgia stand up
and she said we're resilient we have
survived slavery we have survived the
first
jim crow and will definitely survive jim
crow in a siesta suit in 2021
one wonders when black
americans don't have to be resilient
resilient enough to survive something as
appalling as slavery
when they can just go about their
business and exercise their democracy
well you know that's a very good
question and observation
and the fact of the matter is the again
these draconian laws
should not be uh enforced
uh or should not be passed around this
country
um but they are being passed and that
just means
that we do have to and we will be
vigilant by the way we're going to
always
be vigilant in fact my mom used to say
that every generation has to
re has to earn its its keep or its
freedom
so freedom is just not a permanent thing
we would hope that there would be a day
where that would happen
as you may remember my father in his
last speech
talked about getting to the promised
land and he said i've
been to the mountaintop i've seen the
promised land
i may not get there with your but i know
that we as a people
will get to the promised land and that
meant all people not just black people
but all people
who are suffering uh in our nation and
really around the world
and so again we continue to be vigilant
and ultimately we will one day address
these issues
in a way and new governing people will
be put in place
so that all of the people are
represented
truly with fairness and equity i'm glad
you brought up your parents
um coretta scott king martin luther king
jr
um you are the oldest living child just
to give people who don't know your
context
with everything that your father went
through with everything your mother went
through with everything you've been
through
how do you feel as an american today
i i certainly feel very saddened about
where we are
but i'm also very hopeful because there
are young people all over the world
protesting for right um
and and so that's that's that is
certainly inspiring
yeah i have a we my wife and i have a 12
year old daughter
uh and she's an activist a social
justice activist but there are many
young people
her age who are you know when i was her
age i didn't know
anything about the issues that were
going on around the world
but she knows about the issues she knows
about gun violence
she knows about these voting issues
and she and her friends are standing up
with
others across this nation the parkland
students they
are protesting in a positive way in fact
tragically after george floyd and i know
where
the child is going on right now
tragically after his death
there were civil rights demonstrations
in every state in our nation
the largest we've ever seen many of
those led by white
young people but it was whites it was
blacks it was
uh latinos hispanics it was asians it
was uh
wealthy people it was poor people so all
coming together and of course
protests obviously taking place in
europe taking place in australia
taking place in south america uh on the
african continent just about every
continent
and he's thinking i'm i'm hopeful
please forgive me for jumping in there
but i really want to know what would you
tell
george floyd if you could speak to
george floyd what would you tell him
well first of all what i hope
and and speaking to george floyd if i
could speak to george floyd we wouldn't
be at this moment
uh we are a pivotal moment in the
history of our nation
oftentimes when policemen are charged
they are very rarely if ever convicted
my hope is that a conviction occurs but
the sad part about it
is this man should not have had to lose
his life
for you know it doesn't matter in this
context because
but it was certainly a small crime but
the fact of the matter is he was asking
for help
and this policeman stood on his neck and
we saw the breath taken
away from him and that should not have
happened
that should never happen again
policemen have to be held accountable
and
if justice uh with a conviction
uh is not seen that's the thing that i
worry about uh and obviously the city of
minneapolis
we're gonna have to leave it there i'm
so sorry we're gonna have to leave it
there thank you so much for talking to
us
martin luther king iii thank you so much
thank you